Gloria not her real name says she was
pregnant when she was gang raped by
fighters from the M23 Rebel group
earlier this year
m23's fighting government forces here in
the east of Democratic Republic of Congo
it's widely understood to be a proxy of
neighboring Rwanda although Rwanda
denies it
Gloria says M23 Fighters came into the
bar she ran started drinking beer and
smashing bottles
three men raped me before I felt
unconscious there was nobody to help me
when I woke up I was in hospital my
neighbor had rescued me I don't know
what they used because I was badly torn
and my bladder was leaking
Gloria's baby died before she gave birth
and was surgically removed
now she's joined the nearly 200 000
people who've fled their homes the
conditions in the camps are bad there
isn't enough food or clean water and the
shelters don't keep out the rain and
while Congo's Army and most of its armed
groups are accused of widespread rights
abuses the fact that tens of thousands
of people have chosen to come here
leaving behind their homes and their
Farms gives some indication of just how
scared they are of M23
rwanda's Army and the armed groups who
supported have been accused of carrying
out massacres and rights abuses in
eastern Congo since the 1990s it's
always denied the allegations Rwandan
soldiers were photographed with M23
Fighters five months ago we asked M23
about reports of Rights abuses its
spokesman sent this video clip denying
all the allegations made in this story
who are these people there are so many
people who are extremists they are
talking nonsense to destroyers they are
working with the government
when Congo's Army defeated M23 nine
years ago we filmed the bodies of
prisoners tied up and shot dead in the
bases they'd fled
some of the prisoners appeared to have
been kept in pits in the ground
which is what this man says M23 did to
him earlier this year
he says M23 Fighters accused him of
supporting enemy militia and beat him
for three days demanding a confession
then he says he was tied up and thrown
in a pit with other prisoners for three
weeks before being released his wife
thought he was dead
you can lean on one way or the other but
you cannot write down and rest when it
rains the water comes in we were looking
like pigs because of the mud in the pit
once a day the garden tie is one arm and
takes the two or three prisoners to the
toilet this is the life we suffered this
school classroom is home for now
outside others are sleeping in shelters
made on broken rocks the struggle for
control of minerals below the ground has
made Eastern Congo the center of
regional conflict and rights abuses for
decades people here wonder if they'll
ever be left in peace Malcolm Webb out
of Zera Gomer Democratic Republic of
Congo